my experience with acting is i'm so
ashamed of the parts that i've done in
the past
icarly fans have been holding out hope
that jeanette mccurdy will change her
mind in return for the show's upcoming
revival
but we might not want to hold our breath
i did the shows that i was on from like
13
to 21 and uh by 15
i was already embarrassed you know my my
friends at 15 weren't like watching this
they're not like oh cool you're on this
nickelodeon show it was embarrassing
and i think i imagine there's a very
different experience
to be had with acting if you're proud of
your roles and if you feel
fulfilled by them the 28 year old who
now hosts the podcast
empty inside played sam puckett for six
seasons on the nickelodeon show that
ended
in 2012.
she later reprised the role on the
spin-off series sam and cat opposite
ariana grande
i'm back where you've been you're in the
bathroom forever
but during her recent podcast interview
with guest anna faris
jeannette said she's done with acting i
i quit a few years ago
to to to try my hand at writing and
directing it's going great
um i could have years ago because i
actually i initially didn't want to do
it my mom put me in it when i was
i'm six and by sort of age i guess 10 or
11 i was the main
financial support for my family and it
was very much like just the pressure of
my family didn't have a lot of money and
this was kind of the way out
um which i actually think was was
helpful in
driving me to some degree of success
jeannette adds that she quit
after her mom died in 2013. and she went
into detail about the embarrassment she
says she felt over the types of acting
projects she did
my experience with acting is i'm so
ashamed of the parts that i've done in
the past i resent my career
in a lot of ways i think like i i feel
so
non unfulfilled by the roles that i
played and felt like it was the most
just like cheesy embarrassing she also
recounts a conversation she
overheard her mom having with her agent
when she was 10 years old
after she didn't book a role in the 2005
film
because of winn-dixie the part ended up
going to anna sophia robb
my agent i literally hear her on
speakerphone go well jeannette
is not they want a um ethereal beauty
janette is not an ethereal
ethereal beauty she is homely she reads
homely and i was like
okay i guess i read homely as for
whether she could ever imagine returning
to acting
she said it all depends on the
opportunity and being able to
collaborate with a director she really
admires
i do feel like i have i have a point of
view and i have vision and i feel
confident in that and i and i
um and we'll see where things are in a
few years so it sounds like icarly fans
will just have to get by without sam
puckett
i started the show when i was 13. i
still get just as excited when people
come up to me and say they like episodes
or that they love
the show um just because it's it's
really sweet and when people say like oh
i watched your show with my
my mom yesterday and we cracked up like
it's just a really good feeling
but fans can look forward to seeing
miranda cosgrove
nathan kress and jerry traynor it's
really cool
the show's revival which will air on
paramount plus was
announced in december check out this pic
miranda posted from their reunion on set
with her co-stars so i'm excited